- The very first time I left the ground
in a gyroplane, I knew it was over.
My life was done, it was always
going to be about gyroplanes.
And it was not just
because I was in the air,
but I was depending upon myself,
so my safety was in my own hands.
It was one of the most
exhilarating sensations
that I've ever received in my life.
My name is George Jacob,
and I'm known as “Gyro Jake.”
I build gyroplanes from scratch.
What a gyroplane is,
basically a hybrid airplane
helicopter, but it's neither of the two.
How many gyroplanes?
I would say I've built close to 20.
I lost count around 13 a few years back.
I imagine what I want, and what components
should fit together, then I machine out
and weld up the parts that are necessary
to get the job completed.
So sometimes it can take two months,
sometimes it can take a year.
There's times I look at it, and I go,
"Man, I did that, and it works?!
"And I wanna fly it?"
When I first started it was a pretty small
clique in Florida.
And so we'd get together on the weekends.
Today, the gyro community has probably
increased by a hundred-
fold, especially with
the new revolution of
the factory-built gyros.
The do-it-yourself builders
are kind of like the dinosaurs.
They're on their way to being extinct.
There aren't many people that spend
most of their free time
building a gyroplane,
one after the other, after the other.
There's no incentive, like money,
that compels me to do this.
It's just because this is my pleasure,
this is my joy, this is my passion.